hey 42 here in the Philippines you can
be charged with the crime of unjust
vexation for doing just that vexing
someone in the Arctic town of lung gear
bein dying is against the law this is
because bodies don't decompose in the
permafrost so if you fall terminally ill
you will hastily be dispatched by plane
to the Norwegian mainland where you can
die without being arrested in Mobile
Alabama it is against the law to throw
confetti or spray silly-string
in Saudi Arabia it's illegal for any
woman to drive a car or vote in a
general election although this is due to
be changed in 2015 in Singapore chewing
gum is illegal if you get caught dealing
chewing gum you can get fined up to
$2,000 there is a law in South Carolina
called the no muck proposal law which
states that anybody above the age of 60
is not allowed to perform a proposal if
they don't really mean it in Montana
proxy weddings are allowed for those
serving in the military which means a
friend can pretend to be the groom or
the bride and the marriage will still be
considered valid in some cases both the
bride and the groom are absent in
Arkansas there still exists a law from
the eighteen hundreds that states a
husband is allowed to beat his wife but
only once a month the UK has its fair
share of unusual laws in Britain it is
illegal to handle a summer in suspicious
circumstances also in Britain it is
illegal to import potatoes into England
or Wales if you have reasonable cause to
believe that they are polish in Britain
it is illegal to operate a cow whilst in
tux
cated in York England it is perfectly
legal to shoot a Scotsman with a bow and
arrow on any day except Sundays in
England it is actually illegal to be
drunk in a pub in Liverpool England it
is illegal for a woman to be topless
except as a clerk in a tropical fish
store in parts of India a man who is in
debts can offer up his wife as
collateral until the debt is paid in
Hong Kong there's a law that allows a
wife to kill her husband if she finds
him cheating
however she must kill him with her bare
hands
only in Samoa it is illegal to forget
your wife's birthday in France it is
illegal to name a pig Napoleon in Russia
Vladimir Putin just recently made it
illegal to tell kids that gay people
exist in La Crosse with constant it is
illegal to worry a squirrel in Alabama
it is illegal to wear a fake mustache
that causes laughter in church in
Pacific Grove California molesting
butterflies can result in a $500 fine in
Florida it's against a law to dream
about another man's wife or cow in
Minnesota it's illegal to sleep naked
and finally in Virginia and Wyoming it's
illegal to tickle women thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42